those people looking for a job maybe a
career change had a lot of opportunities
today the county hosted a job fair at
the Las Vegas Convention Center and as
Brian will reports from hotels to health
care more than a hundred companies were
ready to hire people
Las Vegas saw an increase of 58 000 jobs
this month but the unemployment rate in
Nevada Still Remains at 5.5 percent it's
a real opportunity for people to get a
job and the jobs that we have here are
an array of jobs the spring job fair
here at the Las Vegas Convention Center
is offering job Seekers access to more
than 130 employers with more than twenty
thousand job openings and it can be as
easy as turning in your resume with some
getting on the spot interviews and even
job offers for the most part it's been
very difficult in the last year to hire
people doing job fairs as many as I can
we're got postings everywhere it's the
candidates were
entry level we're hiring people training
them on the job it's the turnover has
been a little crazy while employers are
in need of quality candidates job
Seekers like Eric Porter are looking for
their next opportunity I was referred to
come down there to be a lot of employers
here that would hire on the spot and
right now in this current job market you
got to get in and work a little harder
so I figure I could kill two birds with
one stone by coming down a day and
seventeen-year-old Tyson ditman is
looking for something better I'm
employed but I just need to get a better
job
so Brian will also tells us in fact more
than 6 000 people were expected at that
job fair today and the companies that
were at that event by the way also have
those positions listed on their website
and we have a link to that on ours at
8newsnow.com